well first of all thank you very much
for this incredible turnout I would have
wished to have this kind of a turnout
than I did last Action Hero
but anyway I want to thank first of all
my co-chairs secretary Schultz and
Warren Buffett for the only being the
co-chairs but also for assembling
helping me assemble this great team of
the best and the brightest economic
leaders and business leaders of
California we just finished a meeting
when I came to California 35 years ago
this was a place of great dreams this
state said to the people everywhere come
here work hard play by the rules and
your dreams can come true what has
happened to California what has happened
to that feeling what has happened to the
optimism that this state once
represented to the world now I believe
that we are in my heart that we can
bring that optimism back the people of
this state are working hard they're
raising their families and they're
paying their taxes our businesses are
the most innovative on the face of this
earth we still have all the elements
that made us great and prosperous we
have everything we need except
leadership in simple terms this is the
financial situation that we face it's
not that the people of California have
been under taxed it is that the
politicians have overspent Sacramento
has overspent overtaxed and
over-regulated our businesses our
elected officials have failed the people
they have overburdened our businesses
which are downsizing and leaving and the
jobs are leaving with them we want those
jobs that are going to Nevada and
Arizona and Texas and elsewhere to come
we want those jobs back I have just met
with my economic recovery council to
address the economic environment of
California California's economy is
critical to the national economy we must
fix California's economic environment
not only for ourselves but for the rest
of the nation businesses cannot continue
to suffer on the skyrocketing workers
compensation costs the day I'm sworn in
I will take action I will call a special
session of the legislature to enact
reforms to correct the system that
imposes unaffordable costs on our
employers while denying decent benefits
to our people that are injured I will
not sign a budget without workers
compensation reform our working men and
women deserve better and our economic
recovery demands and depends on reform
the economic recovery council and I
discussed many other substantive issues
that will be addressed in my
administration litigation reform
regulatory reform and the unemployment
insurance fund crisis and without needed
energy reform California will continue
to suffer the highest commercial energy
costs in the nation they these critical
issues must be addressed to ensure the
economic recovery that California so
desperately needs needless to say the
elephant in the room when it comes to
California second economy is the state
irresponsible operating deficit and the
massive debt that this governor has
allowed California to incur in a Maria
and I we teach our kids the basic
principles we teach them don't spend
more money than you have that's what I
teach my 6-yard and I promise you that
is what I will teach Sacramento
we must have a constitutional spending
cap
we must never gain permits Sacramento to
mortgage our children's future the
unconstitutional deficit spending we
must immediately attack the operating
deficit head-on now does this mean that
we're going to make cuts yes does this
mean education is on a table know that
this mean I'm willing to raise taxes no
additional taxes are the last burden
that we need to put on the backs of the
citizens and businesses of California
one message that became loud and clear
at this last meeting we just had was
that no one not even the economic and
academic leaders could figure out and
make heads or tails of the state's
budget we don't know what is being spent
and we don't know well one thing I've
learned in business and that is that you
can't make sound decisions based on
faulty information upon becoming
governor I will immediately appoint an
outside auditing group free of political
influence to examine the books and find
out how bad the situation really is we
will be this will be a 60-day review
they will result in immediate steps to
address the operating deficit the second
part of the problem is that the next
governor would inherit inherit what
experts think is between 12 and 20
billion dollars this is a dead separate
and apart from the operating deficit
California will not be an attractive
place to do business it will not be
attractive to business the financial
community as long as our credit rating
is the worst in a nation I have asked
the Hoover Institute Chang Hogan
and member of my council to lead the
working group charged with restructuring
this inherited debt now before there
carping begins about the need for the
twenty five point plan and each one of
those items let me make one thing clear
that this problems these problems that I
just mentioned were not created in two
weeks nor we would be able to solve
those problems in two weeks and anybody
that is out there in telling the people
of California otherwise are just a
typical politician the way I work is to
get as many people at the table as
possible listen to the opinions think
about their ideas and then I make the
decision let me tell you something one
thing that the citizens of California
can count on is that I would take action
thank you very much for listening and I
would like now to have my two co-chairs
make some comments again thank you very
much for being the co-chair one if you
please make some comments before we
answer some questions thank you very
much I first became aware of just how
bad the fiscal situation was in
California and how important it was for
leadership that would attack the problem
early in June at that time California
needed to sell 11 billion dollars in
warrants those are securities that come
due in less than a year approximately a
year in California found out that its
credit card was no longer acceptable in
the investment world they presented it
and it was handed back to them and they
were told the state was told get
somebody to guarantee that you'll have
access to the credit markets in the next
year so they got a syndicate of seven
investment banks led by Merrill Lynch
and eighty-four million dollars was paid
not to borrow money but simply to assure
investors that someone somewhere would
lend money to California in the next 12
months if they don't Merrill it's in
their group will get a very very hefty
fee for providing the money so when a
state gets to the position where a
syndicate of investment banks are
regardless is a better credit than what
I believe is the richest and most
important state in the Union a change is
needed and that change is going to
require someone determined who is
credible to the investment world to
present a plan for a balanced budget and
as Arnold said this wasn't created in a
couple weeks and it doesn't get solved
in a couple weeks but within the next
year because if June comes around of
next year and that problem has not been
addressed it won't be solved for 84
million dollars and it won't be solved
for 184 million dollars creditors if
creditors like oxygen you know when you
have it you don't even notice it and
when you don't have it it's the only
thing you're thinking about and we got
very close to that point in California
in June and without the problem being
addressed it'll be around here in spades
next June there are 35 million plus
Californians counting on leadership
they're gonna have to feed their
families tomorrow and next week and next
month the next year and they're gonna
feed them only one way and that's if
they have jobs and they're only going to
have jobs in one way also and that's if
employers expand their businesses and
and come to California just like they
did in the past years the state has
provided millions and millions and
millions of jobs over the years but in
recent in in particularly the recent
couple years that the trend has gone the
other way and that has to be reversed
because 35 million people aren't going
to eat otherwise and they're gonna
they're going to die' tops and after
looking at the situation i felt only new
leadership would get that job done and
take care of those 35 million people and
that's why I'm out here with Arnold
Schwarzenegger thanks
thank you very much there's a new
four-letter word that we're gonna pay a
lot of attention to and Warren just
talked about it jobs that's gonna get a
lot of emphasis I found this morning's
meeting with Arnold Schwarzenegger to be
a very enlightening one and I learned
three things number one I saw this man
sit with a diverse group bearing
opinions and they told him what they
thought what they thought and he
interacted with them he listened in an
active way some people just sit and you
think you don't know whether they're
listening or not other people engage
with the person who's talking so you
know they're listening so I saw him do
that and then I'm sitting next to him
I'm watching him I've learned a little
bit about people and I see he's making
his mind up himself he'll listen but
then he'll decide and then as I've
listened to what the decisions are and
the things these emphasized including
the things he talked about just now I
like what I hear those decisions as
being so I'm delighted to be here in
supporting Arnold Schwarzenegger I live
in California
I intend to stay here I love it my state
is in deep trouble and we need a leader
who can take us out of it and make our
Golden State golden again thank you very
much thank you but by the way I just
wanted to say that it is not
coincidental that secretary Schultz is
on my right and Warren Buffett is on my
left such they don't make sure that you
know where the positioning comes from
that's okay but their concern is they
know they know no
after some taxes
well again I think that I'm very very
much a believer that our people here in
this state have not been undertaxed that
the government is overspent having said
that it is clear that we can't ever say
never because we can have you know next
year an earthquake we can have a natural
disaster we could have a terrorist
attack or something like that so we can
never say never no but I am in principle
against taxing because I feel that the
people of California have been punished
enough from the time they get up in the
morning and flush the toilet they're
taxed then they go and get a coffee
they're taxed they get into their car
they're taxed they go to the gas station
they're tax to go for lunch to tax and
this goes on all day long
tax tax tax tax tax so even when they go
to bed you can really go into bed in
fear that he maybe get taxed while
you're sleeping there's a sleeping tax
this is crazy this is what this state
does and this is why so many businesses
have left so I believe very strongly and
this is why we had this economic summit
is to bring back a business environment
and bring back revenues the natural ways
through businesses the way it was like a
statement I came here in 1968 you know
when I was here businesses wanted to
come to California from all over the
world I remember when I went to Austria
or to Italy or the Japan with met
bodybuilding tourists and so people were
saying oh I cannot wait to get to
California it's the greatest place in
the world now when I go over there and I
just had my last promotion to her people
said I'm gonna stay away from California
I don't want to do business in
California right now because they cannot
figure out what's going on they are in
trouble they have the worst credit
rating they have the worst money
management they have one of the worst
education system on and on and on and on
they just went through that and they are
very much aware because this is on the
front page of their magazines in loose
papers because remember California is
not just another little state it's not
just another little place that you can
find on a map as a very important it's
always considered the greatest
state of the greatest nation and that's
why everyone came in that's why so many
immigrants came so it's two questions
okay let me answer first the first maybe
cuz okay first of all I have to correct
you in all due respect it's not easy to
make cuts because you know no but it is
also not easy even to talk about it's
not easy because you have to look at the
whole thing carefully but the thing that
we have to realize is is that this
budget is as I said in my speech so
crazy that even though I have met for
the last 14 days the top economic
leaders and people that deal with that
from the academic community to deal with
this come to me and I said what is
really the current operating deficit and
they will come up with numbers like five
billion dollars the next meeting I have
to say six billion dollars the next
meeting I have is is to say nine billion
dollars the next meeting I have is is is
seven point eight exactly those are them
so how can you make really good
decisions what you have to do is and
what I have to do when I go into offices
is have an audit like I said as sixty
they audited an independent company to
really look at that I mean this is one
of the things in our economic conference
just now that came through is it as a
man fact I think David Murdoch was the
one that mentioned is it the first thing
he does many parts of businesses to look
at the line-item and do the accounting
to check out what is going on so we can
make the right decisions and that is
something that we can't make right now I
cannot make that right now because we
don't really know the answers so it is
one thing we know is we don't want the
tax more and and that that in every
business when you really are that many
get into it and you look for efficiency
you find places where you can cut even
though you're not laying off anyone are
doing anything but that's what we have
to do is we look at every
Department carefully and then see where
we can make those cuts first of all I
told Warren
if you mentioned prop 13 one more time
used to do 500 situps so he's not gonna
talk about that ever again I can't I
concur on deal because we both grew up
with weightlifting so he knows what that
is like anybody did answer that question
second of all let me just say that prop
13 is something that I have endorsed
that I am a strong believer in and that
I was there two months ago at the
25-year anniversary and I was the
keynote a keynote speaker and the reason
for this is because I've seen firsthand
when that proposition has passed what
effect would impacted had I remember
that old lady in Venice where I used to
train in Gold's Gym when I came out of
there and she came out our house she had
tears in her eyes and I said what what
Samara and she said properties
Proposition 13 has just passed she says
I don't have to sell my home she says
I've been living here for 20 years
my husband died ten years ago she says I
could not afford the property taxes
anymore I would have to move away and
sell the house so it is like it was
hurting the wrong people it was the
wrong idea it's over taxing so therefore
I am a big supporter of proposition 13
and to answer that other question that
you had is it is true that some people
pay low property taxes because they've
been in that house for 20 years but as
soon as you sell that house there is a
whole other valuation of the property
what is the value and then it's based on
that new value so that's why you have
situations sometimes where someone lives
in the house and based maybe just a
thousand dollar property tax in the guy
next door is the same how it kind of
house and based in $10,000 a semi it
or as soon as you sell if it is perfect
is commercial real estate or vidas
residential real estate as soon as you
sell your property
it gets revaluated and there's new
estimates and then this is what you pay
on okay yes sorry right here excuse me
just everyone get the turn please well I
think that it's a very good question
people always concerned I said you know
this is there's a lot of Democrats out
there my answer is is I live with the
Democrat for the last 17 years I'm
trained to deal with Democrats okay my
wife I mean and I we get along really
fine and we make great decisions
together and it is good to have
different point of views I don't think
that I would have a problem with and
remember one thing that proposition 49
the after school education and Safety
Act that passed last year I would not
have been successful with that
proposition would have not been for the
Democrats it was Republicans and
Democrats came together because I went
to them and I said I need you help this
education after-school programs helping
children is not a political issue it is
a people's issue it is a family issue it
is helping the mothers that want to go
to work and not worry about whether
children is real cut you know something
they all got it they endorsed it they
had me up to Sacramento speaking to all
the Democrats and the Republicans no one
was fighting me and it passed by 57% so
that's what I want to do is this is why
I had this meeting here today you would
see the world some of them were
Democrats some of them were Republicans
some of them their different ideologies
and different philosophies they came
from different backgrounds from the
academic world from the business world
but we had one common cause and one
common goal and that is to solve the
problem that we have in California and
bring businesses back to California and
create a business environment in
California that businesses are
to come back but that businesses won't
to stay here so we have to get rid of
this this has to environment towards
businesses because we cannot afford to
have businesses continue moving out of
the state and big workers jobs with them
that's what we want to stop this with
this meeting was but it was Democrats
and Republicans alike we all share the
same interests we all want to make this
a great state it doesn't matter what the
party line is yes actually excuse me
excuse me even though I play even though
I play a machine in a movie but I'm not
a machine so let me just one answer one
question at the time thank you
no no III think that we have to look at
those things you know I'm all for that
people can leave and then you know take
care of the family members and all those
kind of things but I mean it's very
important that we don't continue going
down that road because it is very easy
for all of us and I'm absolutely
convinced that everyone in here will
agree that it isn't because you talked
earlier about it's easy to cut it's also
as easy to promise people programs it's
as easy to go and say we're gonna give
you more on this more on that yeah of
course I want to give away anything and
everything but can be afforded we always
have to come back to one thing and that
is can be afforded as I said I teach my
kids don't spend more than you have we
have to do the same with Sacramento it
doesn't make any sense of course we want
to help everyone we want to reach out to
everyone but can be afforded and do we
therefore destroy our business
environment in California and have
everyone move away sometimes as a
surgeon will say you have to cut to save
the patient and this is what this
situation is here so this is the bottom
line so we have to look at everything
before we promise anything to anyone
right now
I think stop stop stop stop with the
spending and then let's analyze the
whole thing and see what the problems
really aren't where can be cut I mean
this is the thing and let me tell you
something also it's very important for
you to know that it's not that much of
an issue
technically issue because you know
there's many many smart people in
Sacramento there's many smart economists
from both parties it is what is your
willingness what are you willing to do I
have the advantage then I'm going to
Sacramento without any baggage
I haven't made any deals with anyone I
haven't sold out to any special interest
groups
I'm not taking any money from anyone
anyone that comes to me I say look I
will support your cause if it is too
good for that for the better of the
people but not just for you because you
give me campaign contributions I don't
want to get into that I want to go up
there with no baggage no strings
attached I will be totally independent
and therefore I will be able to make
decisions that those guys right now
after in Sacramento will not be able to
make because they already have
taken money they already have sold out
they already have done this that the job
that is enabled it makes it impossible
for them to go and make decisions for
the people it is now an environment in
Sacramento where the politicians the
large extent are representing the
special interest rather than
representing the people and what I want
to do is this is why I always say I will
be a governor for the people for change
because because because I want to
represent the people because the only
thing that counts for me is the people
yes yes but they everyone knows you see
the people you can put wool over their
eyes
you can't put wool over people's eyes
the voters are so smart it is incredible
and they know that the people that are
up there right now have gotten us into
the situation that we are in yes they
know everything that's what I said
earlier they know the details they know
the budgets they know where the
skeletons are hidden and all those
things they know everything but are they
willing to make the changes and are they
willing to work on behalf of the people
and that has been the problem and I will
go this I will goes excuse me let me
finish my sentence thank you I will make
sure that when I go to Sacramento is to
me the first thing that is always in my
mind is the people and when I talk about
people everyone Democrats Republicans
young or makes no difference to me I
will represent everybody but not
representing the special interests that
are paying the politicians so they're
going in their direction that's what I
want to stop so again yes yes
we are you okay so you're right behind
the light so I can see you yeah no
problem well as you know that I'm very
much Pro immigrants I mean I myself came
to this country as an immigrant 35 years
ago so there's no one that understands
those problems better than I I came over
here and I've worked very hard to get
just the temporary working permit then
I've worked very hard for another year
to get a permanent working permit and it
would they call a green card and then it
took me another ten years to get the
American citizenship and I want to
remind you this is my 20 anniversary
this the this in the coming months that
I've got my American citizenship it was
in 1983
so I'm will be having a big big
celebration but I know with immigrants
goes through we all come here to this
country because this is the land of
opportunity it's the place where dreams
come true if we are given this
opportunities and and so I'm all for
that and I will find a way of working
with immigrants and working with
everyone together you know we are very
multicultural a cultural society here
and there's American ago in Los Angeles
when I do my after-school program stays
in Los Angeles like over 100 languages
that you're dealing with you so it's
very complex but it is all doable that
is the key thing and as you know that
I'm a very found of the of the Latin
community and have been doing movies
down in Mexico I've done four of my
movies down in Mexico I have traveled up
and down the coast providing
after-school programs
one of the first after-school programs
that we had was with Danny Hernandez at
the hollenberg Youth Center in East LA
where we built from just 500 kids build
it up to 20,000 kids providing
after-school programs mostly Latinos
actually in the Homburg middle school in
order think so I will do anything that I
can to help you
would come in this country with the
language and bid orders to get enough
tutoring for them and and and and to
have them get jobs and orders but that's
why we have to create a business
environment now so that everyone works I
like to get into the situation that
there is no unemployment this is it's
disastrous the ways red now is six point
six or six point seven percent
unemployment yes over here sorry but I
have to switch over here from the ten
o'clock to the two o'clock yet
say again yeah it's the United Nations
no no well no I let me tell you
something that the public doesn't care
about figures they've heard figures for
the last five years figures and graphs
and percentages and all those kind of
things well you know what the people
want to hear is is are you willing to
make the changes are you willing and are
you tough enough to go in there and
provide leadership that's what this is
about
and I will be tough enough I'm
independent I can go up there in a
really can clean house that's what I
will do me do you need to know the
things yes and that's the auditing would
take care of the rest
yes oh yes a little bit
excuse me just a second Thanks no but
I'm saying that you have to look at
exactly where excessive amounts of
monies are being spent we have so little
information and it is not real true
information it's bad information when
you deal with it like I said earlier
from five Milot billion to nine billion
dollars how can you run a business if
someone if I want to take over business
and I don't have you ever been in the
business or not I obviously know you're
journalists so I mean it's not it's not
anything meant negative but I'm just
saying that when you run a business when
you run a business like David Murdoch's
literally the first thing you do is you
have to find out in the details what is
the problem in order to come up with the
exact solution so it would be wrong for
me to go now and come up with all kinds
of exact solutions to the problem and I
don't know what the problem really is is
so as soon that's why I say we have to
get into that I will make cuts that's
why we have to analyze as time goes on
we maybe will be identifying it but as I
said as soon as they go into office I
will hire an accounting firm a team that
goes in there and really looks at the
whole problem it looks at the numbers in
a very thorough way that is the key
thing and as I also told you that this
problem was created over the last five
years so don't expect any
to thank that this can be solved within
the next few weeks and as I said earlier
anyone that tells the people of
California that they can fix it and can
come up with answers in the next few
weeks is a typical politician say again
I have said from day one in this
campaign that I will concentrate on
moving forward in a positive way I will
do everything I can to go and win in an
October 7th to me that is important to
have a positive campaign and put ideas
forward at a positive rather than going
to worry about what someone else says I
will never attack I will never talk
about anyone I will just think about our
program in our mission it is such a big
job to not only campaign but then to
take over that office why would I worry
about someone else when I was competing
in bodybuilding I never worried about
what someone else how someone else
trained what someone else a the nura's I
made sure that no stone was unturned I
trained five six hours a day I lifted 50
tons of weights a day I did everything I
could to win and I won why would I worry
about everyone else around me what they
say and what they do it's not my style
let everyone talk let everyone make the
statements let everyone make their
apologies where they were wrong the last
five years nor those things I only pay
attention to one thing and this is that
I will be your next governor on October
7th
yes let's go over here please well first
of all let me tell you the reason why
the businesses are leaving is and you
have you've heard it for the last two
hours when we had our council meeting
our recovery council meeting for two
hours we talked about the various
different things that are wounds that
are self-inflicted wounds that are
self-inflicted think about that it's not
like the national economy goes up and
down as it always does
and because of that we're down we used
to be ahead of the curve in any compared
to the national economy now we are below
now they say that if even if the rest of
the country will recover they we will
lag behind self-inflicted wounds like
Brooklyn's conversation you know when I
say they opened it up just before and
said what our problems I mean was like
five six people say recommence come
workers conversation well that is a big
problem and we have the hugest fees than
the energy costs that we have I mean
this is just fees that no one can afford
in I myself I'm in a restaurant business
I know that you have a ten percent
margin on profits so if someone squeezes
you know versed in raises taxes or says
that now your energy costs go up a
hundred percent or your workers
compensation goes up a hundred percent
like it has in the last four years it's
gone up a hundred percent
it's the highest cost in the nation
those are the kind of things where
people just look at it and say as some
members said India I say to my did they
say I don't I'm saying to myself why I'm
not moving out of this state with my
business that's the question that
everyone is asking themselves you can we
are not competitive anymore what we have
to do is we have to control all that we
have to create a better business
environment otherwise people will be
leaving that
only father states like you say to go to
other countries I mean it's great for
India I'm happy for them but the minutes
paid for us we wanted to be want to stop
that we want to really let the
businesses know in California that we
want to have them come back we want that
we have they want them stay here because
that means jobs and when you talk about
jobs that's what every Californian once
I feel bad for anyone that is unemployed
it's unnecessary it's self-inflicted
wounds that we have here the powerful
that the power crisis that we had you
know it's like the energy the costs went
up deals were made unnecessary amounts
are being paid right now we have to
renegotiate those deals with the
contractors I mean it's you know we
really are hurting ourselves and that
has to stop
yes please I'm looking at it right now
because I'm getting from both sides the
input and you know my indication is not
to change the way things are but I want
to hear again both sides because there
may be a very good arguments that I
don't that I'm not the way of I want to
really hear from everybody about this
issue okay and that will let you know
before there is an election there will
be an answer for all of those things so
people really know where I stand on
those things yes yes go ahead
yes well I think this is something that
we are looking into I mean you know I
was a for proper 187 and that is on a
record and it is but this is a federal
issue what we have to do is what is
important is that if the federal
government helped California with the
expenses that occur because of it and I
will negotiate immediately with the Bush
administration if I become governor that
they have them take over some of the
share of the burden okay the last
question last question ideas sure
well I have to tell you something that
is really interesting and it's a very
good question because now I'm done
because as you know that this is a town
where we have obviously more Democrats
than Republicans but it is extraordinary
the amount of actors and actresses and
producers and directors in studio
executives that came forward and said we
want to help you we want to have a
fundraiser Republicans and Democrats
alike so that has been the incredible
thing and that reason is because they
know where my heart is they know that I
want to reach out to everybody they know
the work I've done with Special Olympics
for the last 20 years that had travelled
around the world to create equality
itself and respect for the people with
mental retardation that I went to all
the way to Africa and to China to open
up the stores to get people out of this
those prisons and out of those
institutions people with mental
retardation they know where I stand with
after-school programs and also with
education how much I love education how
much I love children and all is so they
know all those things you know I've got
more words you know in Hollywood here
you mean it there in the words that you
can think of so they support me I feel
good about it now talking about Rob Lowe
I obviously what you read in the papers
wrong Rob Lowe is now the senior advisor
nor he's here an advisor you know so
that's you know but you know how it is
in how it would be the publicity agents
and all those things we have done that
for the last 25 years so we know how
that works so the bottom line is that
Rob Lowe is a very good friend and he
was the first one that they after
announced and called me and says my wife
and I want to support you if you want to
get celebrities together when you have
fundraisers we want to go there - those
fund raisers and all those things any
help that you need I will be ready for
you
that's what Rob Lowe's position is and I
find it very kind of him to offer his
services very kind of his wife and I'm
in heaven when I get office like that so
anyway thank you thank you very much to
all of you remember now one thing let me
just make excuse me excuse me because
you know it was the last question but
let me just make a say something here I
will be out there
any more times I will be seeing all of
you from now to October 7th many more
times there will be many appearances
there will be many visits there will be
many fundraisers speeches even policy
speeches where we will get when it gets
closer to October 7th we will talk about
details you will have all of that so
don't think that I'm going anywhere okay
so you were have a chance to ask many
more questions again I want to stress
thank you all for coming because
remember I am a strong believer that if
it was my bodybuilding career orville is
my acting career I could not have done
it without the press you were always
very helpful it's true even though there
were sometimes negative stories written
so but you know you can't put everyone
in the same path but as a whole I have
been getting such great support from the
press since I came to this country and
you know I don't expect it to go and say
I don't we're gonna help you now with
the campaign and those that's not the
point I'm making I just want you to know
because my wife is a journalist I want
you to know how I know how tough it is
to have your job thank you very much for
being here and though the next time and
though the next time thank you very much
thank you
thank you thank you